You're spinning and I'm spinning and the Earth
is spinning and the sun is spinning and the
solar system and the WHOLE DAMN GALAXY.
BUT WHY!
You might remember from our "How Fast Is the
Universe Moving" video that you're moving
really fast right now.
For example, the Earth is rotating around
it's axis at 1,040 miles per hour (465 m/s).
Planets rotate.
That's what they do, right?
But then science comes along and asks WHYYY…
and once you start thinking about it, it's
staggering.
To figure it out, we have to go back to the
beginning.
Four and a half billion years ago, our solar
system began to form from clouds of helium
and hydrogen -- kind of like a nebula.
As the gas was moved and undulated through
the universe, some of it was denser and some
thinner.
Something, perhaps a nearby supernova, caused
the gases to begin to coalesce, and as the
gravity of these particles increased, they
fell toward each other -- and began to spin.
Funnily enough, every time this happens, the
spin rotates the same direction, counter-clockwise.
There's no UP in space, of course, but if
you think about the angular moment of the
spin as a FORWARD direction, then most things,
Earth, Mars, the Sun… they all rotate counterclockwise.
Because they're all conserving their angular
momentum.
As the gases continued to gravitate toward
each other, constantly moving, they formed
a tossed pizza dough shape.
A ball in the middle, slowly expanding outward
into a disc.
This is the shape we see most often in the
universe, because of the laws of physics.
As interstellar clouds rotate and collapse
onto themselves they fragment, according to
Scientific American, and then those smaller
parts collapse again, and again.
And over the next few hundred million years,
all that gas gathers and fuses into suns,
planets, asteroids and (eventually, after
lots more time) you and me!
All the while, the angular momentum of the
original cloud it maintained; that original
gaseous angular momentum set the stage for
all the rotation to follow -- inertia keeps
it going.
Yes, it IS slowing over time.
A day in 100 years will be 2 milliseconds
longer, but ultimately we'll all keep spinning
unless something big smacks into us.
Strangely, Venus rotates clockwise, and we're
not sure why.
Either the axis of the planet was flipped
upside down at some point, or it slowed rotating
counterclockwise, stopped and began to rotate
the opposite -- possibly due to its dense
atmosphere and closeness to the sun.
It's not the only weirdo; Uranus was knocked
on it's side, her rotation is ALL screwed
up.
Even on a macro level, everything is spinning.
But galaxies, relative to Earth, spin both
clockwise and counterclockwise.
Though spiral galaxies DO tend to spin with
their arms trailing behind them, but even
that isn't a hard rule.
In 2002, the Hubble spotted galaxy NGC 4622
whose arms LEAD her rotation, but they believe
it's because it interacted with another galaxy.
Sounds hot.
In the end, everything in the universe is
spinning.
Energy must be preserved over time; so when
a figure skater spins with his arms in, he'll
spin faster, but with his arms out he'll move
slower.
That's simple physics, but it operates on
a galactic level too!
Does a science question have your head spinning??